welcome to the vast fields of the United
States where over 4 billion pounds of
watermelons are harvested each year
making this country one of the world's
top watermelon producers from Tiny seeds
through the dedicated care of farmers
watermelons have become the symbol of
Summer bringing joy and refreshment to
millions of people around the world join
us as we explore The Miraculous Journey
of the watermelon from seed to The Ripe
fruit on your
[Music]
table it all starts with tiny seeds
carefully selected from the best
watermelon varieties in the United
States millions of these seeds will grow
into healthy watermelon plants ready for
a Bountiful Harvest
[Music]
in just a few days from those tiny seeds
green chuts begin to emerge this is a
critical phase where watermelon plants
need to be nurtured with care to ensure
strong growth
[Music]
but good seeds are just the beginning
the soil must be meticulously prepared
across 130,000 acres of land equivalent
to over 100,000 football fields Farmers
till the soil making it loose and
fertile the soil needs to be just right
providing the roots with the perfect
environment to grow strong
[Music]
and then the newly sprouted seedlings
are planted into the soil each carefully
spaced to give them room to grow with
the help of modern machinery each
seedling is precisely placed into the
pre-prepared furrows saving the farmers
both time and effort afterward a thin
layer of soil is gently applied
retaining moisture and protecting the
young plants from envir enironmental
elements even though the planting
process has become more efficient with
technology the farmer's meticulous care
and dedication remain evident in every
step they don't just see seedlings they
see the promise of the upcoming Harvest
each seedling carries the farmer's hope
ready to take root and grow into vibrant
watermelon plants bearing the dream of a
Bountiful Harvest
[Music]
after 40 50 days from sewing the
watermelon plants begin to flower the
bright yellow blossoms signal the
arrival of the first watermelons this is
the most critical period in the
development process where Farmers must
closely Monitor and carefully adjust the
amount of water and fertilizer in the
United States a variety of watermelon
types are grown each offering unique
characteristics in flavor color and size
each forming watermelon brings us one
step closer to the harvest season
[Music]
after about 90 120 days from planting
The Ripe juicy watermelons are ready for
Harvest with over4 billion pounds
harvested each year the United States is
not only one of the largest producers of
watermelons in the world but also the
home of some of the finest
watermelons Farmers have developed Ved
special techniques to determine the
perfect time to harvest they lightly tap
the Rind listening for that distinct
sound only when the sound is deep and
the Rind is taught is the fruit ready to
be picked the Harvest itself is a
well-coordinated
dance picture this once the watermelon
is deemed ready a farmer expertly slices
it from the vine and with a quick
practiced motion heaves it up into the
air waiting on the back of a truck
another farmer with the skill of a
seasoned Outfield
catches it midair and places it gently
in the truck bed this back and forth
continues as the truck slowly moves
through the field with each watermelon
tossed and caught with the same
precision and care it's a lively and
efficient process filled with shouts of
encouragement and laughter as the team
works together to gather the fruits of
their labor every harvested watermelon
represents not just hard work but also
the camaraderie and deep love for
farming that these Farmers share
hey
he
he hey
[Music]
after being harvested The Ripe
watermelons are transported to
processing facilities here they undergo
rigorous quality checks to ensure the
highest standards before being packaged
and shipped Nationwide and Beyond in
Just 2 to 5 days these watermelons from
the fields of the United States arrive
on your table bringing the fresh sweet
taste of Summer the US exports
watermelons mainly to Canada and some
markets in Europe and Asia contributing
significantly to the global watermelon
Supply the future of the US watermelon
industry is looking brighter with
technological advancements and
sustainable farming practices the United
States is poised to increase both
production and quality to meet the
growing Global demand American
scientists and farmers are continuously
researching and developing new
watermelon varieties from seedless to
thin rind watermelons to provide the
best experience for consumers the goal
in the future is to maintain high
standards and explore new markets
solidifying us watermelons as a symbol
of quality and
[Music]
flavor with each passing season the US
watermelon industry continues to rise
constantly innovating and expanding from
vast fields to the Sweet watermelons on
your table this journey is not just the
story of Farmers but also a symbol of
progress and hope for the future enjoy a
slice of watermelon and you will taste
not only the sweetness but also the love
and dedication in every fruit
[Applause]
[Music]